et on en parle avec vous thierry brault
vous enseignez à sciences po paris
spécialiste de la géopolitique et
l'énergie la russie 1 qui ne coupent pas
le robinet du gaz du moins pas pour
l'instant ça arrange bien les européens
ça
mais encore une fois ça n'arrange pas du
tout les ukrainiens puisque vous parliez
de la diplomatique du portefeuille
rappelons que notre facture gazière et
pétrolière chaque jour que nous devons
veiller à la russie nous revient c'est
un milliard de dollars comment on passe
dans le monde de l'après russie alors
mais je crois que l'on va passer on
entre dans un monde en guerre et donc il
faut trouver des solutions rapides alors
effectivement peut-être aujourd'hui et
demain les chefs d'état ne se mettront
pas d'accord sur un embargo je rappelle
qu'il faut regarder toutes les matières
premières énergétiques c'est à dire le
gaz le pétrole mais aussi le charbon
mais je crois que en fait ce qu'on a vu
aux états unis est sous la pression
populaire et bien joe biden a déclaré
cet embargo alors évidemment aux états
unis ça n'impacte pas trop les des
américains à l'impact un petit peu sur
le prix de l'essence à la pompe nous
cela nous apportera beaucoup plus je
crois que rapidement les chefs d'état
seront obligés sous la pression
populaire de patissia un embargo et donc
il faut trouver la solution de comment
fait sens et là effectivement on va être
obligé de décider que la crise militaire
doit se résoudre avant la crise
énergétique et avant la crise climatique
et donc
revenir à brûler malheureusement et
aurifères cette équipe avant la crise
climatique vous l'avez dit ça veut dire
plus de centrales à charbon alors même
qu'un rapport du giec ce la semaine
dernière un pas plus tard qu il y a cinq
jours nous indiquait que à ce rythme là
et bien nous allions subir très
rapidement les effets de ce
réchauffement on n'a pas d'autre
solution dans l'immédiat thierry brault
que de recourir à nouveau bon vieux
charbon
non malheureusement nous produisons au
maximum de nos capacités en gaz un peu
il reste un peu de capacités résiduelles
une employée dans le pétrole dans les
pays de l'opep hors de la russie est la
seule possibilité aujourd'hui c'est le
charbon est même encore une fois avec ce
charbon de là nous ne sommes pas sûrs de
ne pas avoir des black out en europe
c'est à dire que on va avoir un problème
climatique mais aussi un problème
économique c'est à dire que on va on
risque d'avoir des sociétés qui vont
être obligés de fermer et donc une
récession à nos portes on ne peut
parcourir alors la france elle a le
nucléaire qui lui permet d'une certaine
manière à d'être en partie auto
suffisante ce n'est pas le cas de pays
comme l'italie ou l'allemagne ces pays
là justement ils ne peuvent pas se
tourner vers d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement comme l'algérie par
exemple s'agissant du gaz
encore une fois on parle beaucoup
d'algérie on parle de la norvège mais il
faut se rappeler qu'au prix actuel
aujourd'hui qui sont à des prix records
aucun pays producteurs à part la russie
n'a de capacités résiduelles une
employée ça ne serait pas le sens et
donc pour augmenter les volumes il va
falloir mettre des investissements et
les investissements dans l'énergie que
vous preniez le gaz le nucléaire ou même
non renouvelables ça ne se fait pas en
quelques mois ça se fait plutôt en
quelques années quelques années pour le
renouvelable ou le gaz est presque une
décennie pour le nucléaire donc la
solution va durer bon il faut un on l'a
compris on va sans doute devoir recourir
davantage au charbon si l'europe suit
les américains et les britanniques dans
l'idée d'un embargo que vous semblez
considérer inévitable au plan politique
cela veut dire qu'il va falloir sans
doute aussi investir massivement dans
les renouvelables mais là encore cela va
prendre du temps on ne peut donc
définitivement pas se passer du
nucléaire
absolument on aura besoin du nucléaire
et encore une fois le président macron
avait évoqué 6 à 14 réacteurs nucléaires
je vous rappelle que le pas de deux pour
la construction avec assez long puisque
c'est à partir de 2035 mais encore une
fois nous avons besoin de tout ce qui
est disponible ce qu aux états-unis en
appel au lof d abord c nous avons besoin
de toutes les énergies aujourd'hui nous
ne pouvons pas nous permettre d'en
sélectionner certaines meilleurs que
d'autres en temps de guerre ça ne risque
pas aussi de pousser un pays comme
l'allemagne qui avait tourné le dos au
nucléaire à y revenir
écoutez l'allemagne on nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui parce que nous voyons sous
nos yeux 15 ans d'échec de la politique
énergétique d'angela merkel donc oui
l'allemagne doit reconsidérer sa
politique énergétique l'allemagne est
souveraine elle décidera ce qu'elle veut
pour le moment elle a décidé juste et
north stream 2 force et encore une fois
par des américains mais elle devra
effectivement décider de comment elle
veut faire je rappelle que ce merkel on
a effectivement arrêté des centrales
nucléaires pour dans les années
2011-2014 relancer les chambres plus de
sobriété aussi dans la consommation
certains observateurs comme jean marc
jancovici le dise crise russe ou pas il
faudra de toute manière réduit notre
consommation car nous arrivons au pic de
la production pétrolière mondiale
alors je ne crois pas qu'on arrive ni au
pic de la production pétrolière mondiale
ni au pic de la production gazière
mondiale y en a suffisamment de réserves
malheureusement pour avoir un
réchauffement climatique encore plus
encore plus grand c'est pas ça le
problème le problème c'est effectivement
la sobriété énergétique j'ai toujours
pensé que la sobriété énergétique en
temps de paix était compliquée à mettre
en oeuvre je parlais en disant souvent
que la sobriété énergétique heureuse
n'existe pas par contre en temps de
guerre nous sommes obligés de le faire
donc c'est peut-être aussi une occasion
de revoir nos comportements
effectivement en consommant moins merci
thierry brault d'avoir été avec nous